let's think about how we would account
we would have accounted for things if
instead of renting our building for
$200,000 instead we bought the building
for two million dollars how would have
that showed up how would that have shown
up on from an accounting profit point of
view and an economic profit point of
view so we're going to buy we're going
to buy our building for two million
dollars so that is the market value of
our building at the beginning of our
period at the beginning of year one and
let's say at the end of year one so this
this is year one right over here that
occurs and maybe to a large degree this
is because I use the building there was
a lot of traffic in there became maybe
was a brand new building before and now
it's essentially kind of the building
itself has taken some wear and tear and
because of that the market value of the
building is now 1.9 million dollars so
essentially through this year the
building's value has depreciated by
$100,000
so we'll say the depreciation is
$100,000 notice I didn't pay anyone that
hundred thousand dollars it was not an
explicit it was not an explicit
opportunity cost but this really is an
opportunity cost because I've this I
spent that this hundred thousand dollars
is the opportunity cost of not selling
the building a year ago and instead
using that building I have essentially
lost out on a hundred thousand dollars
now that's not all that I have lost out
on I have also lost out on the ability
to invest this two million dollars in
other things maybe I could have got
maybe I could have invested the two
million dollars at a five percent rate
and gotten some interest on it so I also
have the opportunity cost opportunity
cost of capital of capital of not
investing that two million dollars
someplace else and so the opportunity
cost of capital let's say I could have
gotten I could have gotten five percent
on my two million dollars so five
percent of two million is $100,000 so my
opportunity cost of capital right over
$100,000 another way to think about it
is let's just say that I buy the
building and I sell it at the end of the
year then I would have literally lost a
hundred thousand dollars on that
transaction and although I might have
used it so I got some value out of it
and I would have lost another hundred
thousand dollars by not having that
money invested in some other use during
that period so these are the two non
explicit costs that will come in - that
would show up in our profit statements
now this depreciation depreciation is
something that is accounted for by
accountants when you look at a company's
financials you will see something called
depreciation which is a measure of how
are you you're kind of using up your
capital goods you are using up your
building you are using up your equipment
you are using up your your vehicles or
whatever else you might have economists
are very pure about depreciation they
say what was the market value at the
beginning of the period what is the
market value at the end and so the
difference is how much it has
depreciated and this is kind of it's
actually almost a more natural way in
accounting and I won't go into the
details there are many ways to
depreciate something you might be able
to say well if the thing is worth two
million dollars and if it's going to
last me ten years I can depreciate a
hundred thousand dollars a year or
actually two hundred thousand dollars
here two million divided by ten years
and there's different incentives based
on if you are if you are the owner of a
firm of how you depreciate you might
want to actually have a lot of
depreciation for tax purposes so that
you can somehow hide a high day hide a
profit or whatever but for the sake of
this video we're going to assume that
both the accountants and the economists
will will mark off a hundred thousand
dollars of depreciation if we'd about if
we were to buy the building
so let's redo our two financial
statements the accounting version and
the economic version so in the
accounting version so let me copy and
paste all of this so copy and let me go
down here and paste it let me paste it
and so now now we don't have any rent
expense instead of renting the building
we've gone off and we've bought the
building so let me get rid of that so
our rent expense is now going to be zero
is now going to be easy
but we do have a depreciation expense
and I'll write that in another color we
do have a depreciation expense of one
hundred of one hundred thousand dollars
and we don't think about the opportunity
cost of capital what we could have done
what we could this is opportunity cost
of capital what we could have done with
that two million dollars that we used to
buy the building
and so our pre-tax profit our pre-tax
accounting profit pre-tax profit from an
accounting point of view is going to be
is going to be let's see 50 minus 200 is
300 minus another - another let me make
sure I get this right so I have I have
actually it's gotten better because my
rent was 200 and now I only have a
depreciation of 100 so it's 50 minus 350
gives me a pre-tax profit of 150
thousand dollars now let's and that was
because I was renting it for more and
now my depreciation based on how what
happened with the market rate actually
changed less than what my rent would
have been but the economic profit at
least based on the way we've done the
numbers here it'll actually come out
neutral which it should because we
really economic profit we're just trying
to decide does it make sense for us to
run this business in this way and so
when we look at the economic profit
let's copy and paste this again so we're
going to let me copy just this part so
copy and paste and maybe if things
actually did improve when we actually
changed how we how we whether we owned
or rent then that would say well that's
the more economic way to do it so let's
say this year to year or this is year
one again but now we're doing this is
economic profit year one so our food is
the same our labor is the same our rent
disappears we get rid of that let me get
rid of the rent the rent is now going to
be zero we now on our building rent is
zero these are all our explicit costs
these are direct outlet outlet these are
direct payments of money to someone else
but now let's think about our implicit
costs implicit implicit costs well we
still have the same implicit cost that
we had up here we have the wages
foregone we
talked about maybe I was a doctor and
I'm not working as a doctor to run this
restaurant so my wages foregone or
$150,000 wages foregone for God are
150,000 never actually I think wages
wages lost are 150,000 dollars and now
we have the depreciation on top of that
I'll do this in magenta to show what is
new we have the depreciation of $100,000
and on top of that we have the
opportunity cost of capital the return
we could have gotten on that two million
dollars that instead we used to buy the
building so I'll call it I'll call it
OCC opportunity cost of capital in this
situation was the 5% of two million
dollars another $100,000 $100,000 so the
way that I've worked out the numbers
here we we didn't have to spend two
hundred thousand on rent
but we increased our implicit costs by
owning the building by two hundred
thousand so it all comes out the same we
still get what we got in the previous
one of an economic profit of negative
one hundred thousand dollars negative
one hundred thousand of economic
economic profit economic profit and this
of course was accounting accounting
profit and so what I wanted to really
just highlight in this is that you don't
get kind of a freebie on the economic
profit when you decide to buy instead of
rent or a rent versus buy you there are
still ways of accounting for essentially
the opportunity cost of doing any of
these actions